[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at
eight pm makes you a better mom to pour
yourself a glass
let's talk tonight we're gonna drink
some Chardonnay and it's actually cold
which usually I just put ice cubes in it
feeling pretty classy right now so
here's why I'm drinking tonight bring it
back I've had the same song stuck in my
head for the past three days and it's
not like a normal song that's on the
radio it's a kids TV show song and I'm
not gonna have it because one we don't
have the rights and two I don't want to
get it stuck in your head I wouldn't
wish this upon my worst enemy so on that
note let's talk about the worst things
about kids TV shows gonna be a 15 minute
episode so first the reason why I'm
drinking the music in these kids TV
shows it's so catchy it's so repetitive
the tune is just so like
singsong so I can just be in the same
room as my son watching one of these
shows and the whole song is stuck in my
head for the next three weeks like I'll
be at work and I'll like inadvertently
start humming or even fun singing these
songs and I'll be like you have fun then
you share I look up and everybody's
looking at me like what this what like
I'll find myself on the third week of
having the song stuck in my head singing
myself to sleep like rocking back and
forth in my bed like if you happen you
must share and I Hannah sleep tight
so I really wish I had a solution for
this there's no way around it to be
honest unless you're willing to invest
in a lifetime supply of earplugs we're
all kind of sunk next caillou
you all know what I'm talking about but
before I get started just
[Music]
now I'm ready
where do I even start about this shitty
ass kid first of all if you haven't seen
it don't don't google it don't YouTube
it trust me you've been warned
don't do it ty you is every parent's
worst nightmare Caillou is like this
weirdly ambiguous child and I think they
said that they tried to make it to
represent every child but it's like he's
just a bald white kid so way to go on
representation there and he talks in
this voice that's like mom well touch my
painting mom Rosie she's touching my
dream you know what he's happy his voice
is like that oh it's this voice that
like gets under your skin and like feels
like spiders curling under your skin and
then the poor parents are just like dead
inside you'll see Caillou like what
wealthy bread my toy and the parents
just like Caillou it's okay he nice
sister so basically all it does is teach
your kids to be a douche and it teaches
parents that if your kid is a juice
you're just gonna die inside so
Caillou's mom I know you got a stash
wine in your bedroom and you're just
like chugging that [ __ ] the second the
kids go to bed this one's for you
next these shows suck you right in these
shows are made for kids but I swear
they're also inadvertently made for
parents to like also get involved in
these because my son will be watching it
I'll be folding laundry on the other
side of the room and he's like watching
some show and they're asking him Oh what
do I need to see glasses a saw a chair
course I'm gonna be like the glasses and
then my kids like mom I was guessing
even after my son has like fully
finished watching and left the room to
go play in his room I'll continue
watching them for like a good 20 more
minutes my husband actually worked in
the house one time but I was sitting on
the couch watching Dora the Explorer
sitting there like the Mack and I just
wanted children show that I can ignore
is that too much to ask
[Music]
next the adventures the majority of
these kids TV shows involve the main
child character going on some crazy
adventure to do something absolutely
phenomenal to like save the world
I can't live up to that it's like my son
watches these shows and he's like mom
can we go on a pumpkin space ride and
I'm like yeah and the worst show for
this is Dora the Explorer because she's
like four and her parents just let her
wander wherever the hell she wants and
she gets to go through the Forbidden
Forest
oh that's Harry Potter she gets to go
through like the Magic Mountain and like
climb trees and go off she has like a
monkey chaperone who would trust a
monkey to chaperone a child but she's
just off in the world wandering around
from city to city just picking up
friends on the way talking to strangers
as his weird creepy Fox trying to rob
her all the time it's like
that was my kid I'd be like you stayed
the [ __ ] inside what are you doing going
outside I don't care if this Blue Bird
lost its mom it can figure its own [ __ ]
out none of my kids watch that and
they're like why can't I go wander
around the neighborhood alone but
because the real world is not like Dora
the Explorer I'm sorry child why aren't
there kid shows with adventures in
folding the laundry or like drying the
dishes or swiffering the floor kids are
super impressionable as long as you
present something in a cool way they'll
want to do it so instead of Dorothea for
why isn't there like Chad the kid who
helps out around the house that's the
kind of show I like my kids to watch
Kevin even draw speaka kids series about
cleaning he's a really great cartoonist
he's gonna do this Kevin you animate it
[Music]
so last real-life adults there's
something very unsettling about adults
on kids TV shows especially if it's a
cartoon show with a real live adult
because they're adults
but then on these shows they're
pretending to be really interested in
like a warm glass of milk with dinner
I'm watching this thinking no you
definitely do some weird [ __ ] on the
weekends if the only exception is the
wiggles and Blue's Clues because the
Wiggles are awesome and they're super
cute and the yellow one is super cute
and Steve from Blue's Clues is a babe I
don't know why they replaced him with
Joe dislike knockoff orange shirt
character it's like Christmas and
suddenly color wise men wear this
foreign shirt you're wanting to get to
appreciate a new character when you
already fall in love Steve but it's
brilliant LA - I see if you're Joe and
you like all these weird new stuff is
you do you don't just sketch beautiful
pictures in your notebook you've all
this other weird stuff like he was just
trying to sketch a nice pictures a
notebook find the clues is like high
defeat basically no soap on and then
they branch out this new person who's
just Excel do you see what I'm doing see
what I'm doing I'm like so into this and
it's not even a show for me so I guess
they're awful but they're doing their
jobs really really well
Joe stocks Steve rolls
that's like offer today I'm Hannah your
friendly neighborhood wine mom and if
there's a show that I missed that you
particularly don't like leave it in the
comments because my youngest Sanne is
about the age to start watching TV and I
need to know what to avoid because I'm
sure there's a new Caillou at this point
and as always if there's a topic that
you'd like me to talk about in the next
episode leave that in the comments too
because I love talking about what you
guys want to hear til next time
where's my TV remote
[Music]